A couple years ago, Erin went to live in Poland. And she went with certain prejudices. She was Jewish, and she was scared of anti-Semitism. Now, many Poles will tell you that this prejudice is completely unfair. But Erin lost Polish family members in the Holocaust. And Poland's where some of the most infamous concentration camps operated, Auschwitz and Birkenau and Treblinka.
几年前，艾琳去了波兰生活。她带着某些偏见而去。她是犹太人，且对反犹太主义感到恐惧。现在，许多波兰人会告诉你，这种偏见完全是不公平的。但艾琳在犹太人大屠杀中失去了波兰的家人。而波兰正是奥斯威辛、比克瑙和特雷布林卡等最臭名昭著的集中营所在地。
I'd only heard one thing about Poland my entire life, from my mother, from my grandparents, that they had always hated Jews. And they had always wanted to see Jews killed. And then, when the Holocaust started to happen, they were happy to see it happen, and they were collaborators. Even though my mother was saved by a Pole, that was always told to me as, well, she only did it for the money.
我这辈子只从我母亲和祖父母那里听说过一件事，那就是他们一直憎恨犹太人。他们一直希望看到犹太人被杀。当大屠杀开始时，他们很高兴看到这一切发生，并且他们是通敌者。尽管我母亲被一位波兰人救了，但这事一直被描述成：嗯，她那样做只是为了钱。
So you were scared about anti-Semitism there. What did you find?
所以你当时对那里的反犹太主义感到害怕。你发现了什么？
Well, the first thing I found is that I had a roommate with a Hebrew letter tattooed on her shoulder. I found the old Jewish quarter in Krakow, which is where I was living, has been converted into this kind of Jewish theme park. There's Jewish-themed cafes that have matzoh ball soup and latkes, all this Jewish food.
嗯，我发现的第一件事是，我的室友肩膀上纹着一个希伯来字母。我发现我居住的克拉科夫的老犹太区，已经被改造成了一种犹太主题公园。那里有提供无酵饼汤和土豆饼等所有犹太食物的犹太主题咖啡馆。
And they play it with klezmer music. And there's all these pictures of Jews with black hats on the walls. And there's this huge enthusiasm for Jewish culture. And I went to a nightclub with a friend, and the nightclub singer, as part of a set that included all kinds of jazz songs and "When the Saints Go Marching In," all of a sudden started playing Fiddler on the Roof songs.
他们还放着克莱兹默音乐。墙上到处都是戴着黑帽的犹太人的照片。人们对犹太文化有着巨大的热情。我和朋友去了一家夜总会，夜总会的歌手在表演包含各种爵士歌曲和《圣徒列队前进》的曲目时，突然开始演奏《屋顶上的提琴手》中的歌曲。
Now, you brought tapes of this. Here's a recording recorded in the nightclub. Just describe this nightclub.
你带了这些录音带。这是在夜总会录下的录音。描述一下这家夜总会。
It's a nightclub that appeals to the up-and-coming yuppie set of Krakow, 20-, 30-something, really beautiful people in really tight clothes. All the women have midriff-baring, and men are in leather pants, and Euro hipster. When we walked in, she was singing "Yesterday," by the Beatles. But she does a whole diverse set. But her climax, the thing she builds to, is this sort of montage of Jewish music. And the climax of the whole thing is "Hava Nagila."
那是一家吸引克拉科夫新兴雅皮士群体的夜总会，大概20到30多岁，都是穿着紧身衣服的俊男美女。女人们都露着腹部，男人们穿着皮裤，是那种欧式时髦风格。我们进去时，她正在唱披头士乐队的《Yesterday》。但她的表演曲目非常多样。而她表演的最高潮，也就是她极力渲染的，是某种犹太音乐串烧。整个表演的高潮就是《Hava Nagila》。
We should say to people who have never been to a Jewish wedding, this is the old-school, dance at a bar mitzvah, dance at a wedding kind of song.
我们要对那些从没参加过犹太婚礼的人说一下，这是一种老派的、在犹太教成人礼或婚礼上跳舞时才会听到的歌。
And they were just crazy for it. They loved it, loved it.
他们简直为之疯狂。他们爱死这首歌了，非常喜欢。
And Krakow is how close to Auschwitz, the concentration camp?
克拉科夫离奥斯威辛集中营有多近？
It's about an hour's drive, maybe a little less than an hour. A friend of mine, an American Jew visiting me in Krakow, he'd spent the day at Auschwitz. And then I took him to this nightclub. And when the singer starts singing-- first, she's singing Fiddler on the Roof songs, and he thought that was pretty funny because, here, it's a Broadway take on the old country right here in the middle of the old country. And that was sort of kitschy and funny.
开车大约一个小时，也许不到一个小时。我的一位正在克拉科夫探望我的美国犹太朋友，他花了一整天在奥斯威辛。然后我带他去了这家夜总会。当歌手开始唱歌时——起初，她唱的是《屋顶上的提琴手》里的歌，他觉得这很有趣，因为百老汇版本的旧国度音乐，竟然就在旧国度的中心响起。那感觉既俗气又好笑。
And then she started singing "Hava Nagila." And everybody's like, wooooo! And they got all excited, and they jumped to their feet. And they're belly-dancing, and they're singing along. And my friend turned to me, and he says, I'm sorry. Where was I eight hours ago?
然后她开始唱《Hava Nagila》。每个人都欢呼着“噢——！”他们变得非常兴奋，跳了起来。他们在跳肚皮舞，还跟着一起唱。我朋友转向我，说：“对不起，我八小时前在哪儿？”
It can throw you when somebody you thought was your enemy shows up to what you thought was going to be a fight dressed as you, wearing your favorite suit, and those shoes that you thought really only looked good on you. It's hard to throw the first punch in that situation. It's hard to know whether you should stop hating them or not.
当那个你以为是敌人的人，打扮成你的样子，穿着你最喜欢的西装，穿着你以为只有你穿才好看的鞋子，出现在你以为会发生争斗的地方时，这真的会让你感到错愕。在这种情况下，很难挥出第一拳。也很难判断自己到底该不该继续恨他们。
After all, they're trying so hard to be like you. It's almost flattering. Or maybe you should hate them all the more. I mean, the sheer gall of it. There they are, you.
毕竟，他们那么努力地想成为你。这几乎令人受宠若惊。或者也许你应该更加恨他们。我是说，这得有多大的胆量啊。他们就在那儿，他们就是你。
Well, today on our program, Fake ID. We bring you stories of people traveling under fake papers, false identities, not for money, not for power, not for personal gain, but only for their own pleasure and amusement, which, I have to say, makes the whole thing all the more confusing. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天节目的主题是“假身份”。我们为您讲述人们使用假证件、假身份旅行的故事，不是为了钱，不是为了权力，也不是为了个人私利，仅仅是为了他们自己的快乐和消遣，我必须说，这让整件事变得更加令人困惑。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today, Pole Vault. In that act, the very confusing story of a Jew in Krakow among non-Jews who think that Judaism is just kind of cool. Act Two, This Blessed House. In that act, a story from Jhumpa Lahiri about an Indian couple that keeps finding trinkets from a religion that is not theirs, which you think would not really cause much trouble. Act Three, The Lie That Binds. David Sedaris explains how to stay in love. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“撑杆跳”。在这一幕中，讲述了一个关于在克拉科夫的犹太人，身处一群认为犹太教很酷的非犹太人之中的困惑故事。第二幕，“这个受祝福的家”。在这一幕中，讲述了Jhumpa Lahiri创作的一个关于一对印度夫妇的故事，他们不断发现一些不属于他们宗教的小饰品，你以为这不会引起什么麻烦。第三幕，“束缚的谎言”。大卫·塞达里斯解释了如何保持爱情。请继续收听。
Act One, Pole Vault. So, Erin Einhorn went to Poland, to find the Catholic family that had sheltered and saved her mother from the concentration camps during World War II. And she found that in Krakow, where she was living, in a country where the Jewish population had been exterminated, Judaism was suddenly trendy, hip even, for all sorts of reasons.
第一幕，“撑杆跳”。艾琳·艾因霍恩去了波兰，去寻找那个在二战期间保护并挽救她母亲免遭集中营厄运的天主教家庭。她发现，在她居住的克拉科夫，在一个犹太人口已被灭绝的国家，犹太文化突然变得时髦，甚至是潮流，原因有很多。
Jews comprised, at one point in time, 10% of the population and were living throughout that country. So there's cemeteries, buildings. There's just Hebrew letters etched in stone that once said "pharmacy" in Yiddish. Yet most people under 60 have never met a Jew. So when they hear about it, when they get a piece of it, they're excited about it. They're fascinated by it. They're drawn to it.
犹太人曾经占人口的10%，遍布全国。所以那里有墓地、建筑。石头上刻着希伯来字母，曾经用依地语写着“药房”。然而，大多数60岁以下的人从未见过犹太人。所以当他们听到关于犹太人的事，接触到一点相关文化时，他们会感到兴奋。他们对此着迷，被其吸引。
Right, because there are these clues all around, and they feel like, oh, finally, that's what that means.
没错，因为到处都是这些线索，他们感觉，“噢，原来如此，原来这就是那个意思。”
The Polish national television, still under communism, played Fiddler on the Roof at some point in the late '80s on television. And when I was doing interviews this year, people constantly referred to, oh, the first time I saw Fiddler on the Roof. It was this thing that-- their grandmothers would gather them around the television and say, "Oh, look, look, look. That's what it looked like. These are the people I grew up with. It looked like this." One of the other clips I think you have is of a woman who's actually writing her master's thesis about Isaac Bashevis Singer, and is taking Yiddish, and is fascinated by Jewish culture, who the first time she experienced Jewish culture was when they ran Fiddler on the Roof on television.
波兰国家电视台在80年代末期的某个时候播放过《屋顶上的提琴手》。当我今年做采访时，人们不断提到：“噢，我第一次看《屋顶上的提琴手》的时候。”这就是那种——他们的祖母会把他们围在电视机前说：“噢，看，看，看。这就是当年的样子。这就是我一起长大的人。当时就是这个样子的。”我认为你手头还有一段剪辑，是一个正在写关于艾萨克·巴什维斯·辛格硕士论文的女性，她正在学依地语，对犹太文化着迷，她第一次体验犹太文化就是当电视上播放《屋顶上的提琴手》的时候。
Here's that clip.
这是那段剪辑。
My first contact was quite a long time ago, when I first saw Fiddler on the Roof. And it was in the times when we didn't have a VCR at home, so my father would record it on a tape recorder. So I had three hours, and I would listen to that again and again, so that after some time, I knew it by heart.
我第一次接触是很久以前，我第一次看《屋顶上的提琴手》。那时候家里还没有录像机，所以我父亲用磁带录音机录了下来。我有三个小时的录音，我不停地反复听，过了一段时间，我都能背下来了。
And then whenever I had some difficult times, I would go back to the cassette and listen to that, to the songs, and to the humor, and the culture, the different-- well, different to what I've been taught before. I was taught on communist history books. And you had no mention about Jewish people living in Poland. You just said one word about the king Casimir the Great, who invited Jews in the 14th century, then big nothing, and then the Holocaust.
每当我遇到困难的时候，我都会回去听那盘磁带，听那些歌，听其中的幽默，还有文化，那是与——嗯，与我以前受到的教育所不同的文化。我受的是共产主义历史书的教育。书里根本没提犹太人在波兰的生活。只提到了一句卡齐米日大帝在14世纪邀请犹太人，然后就什么都没了，直接跳到大屠杀。
How many Jews were in Poland before the war?
战前波兰有多少犹太人？
In Poland, I think about 3.5 million.
在波兰，我想大约有350万。
And now?
现在呢？
Now it's about 3,000, something like that. And in Krakow, which is where I spent most of my time last year, there's about 170 Jews, most of them over 80.
现在大约有3000人，差不多这样。在克拉科夫，也就是我去年待得最久的地方，大约有170名犹太人，大多数都超过80岁了。
[KLEZMER MUSIC PLAYING]
[克莱兹默音乐播放]
Erin, what's this recording of?
艾琳，这是关于什么的录音？
Yeah, this is the annual Jewish cultural festival in Krakow. And in a country with almost no Jews, it's really an extraordinary thing. The clip you're playing is the final concert of the festival at which, the Polish newspapers reported this year, there were 10,000 participants.
这是克拉科夫一年一度的犹太文化节。在一个几乎没有犹太人的国家，这确实是一件非同寻常的事情。你播放的片段是电影节闭幕音乐会，据波兰媒体今年报道，有10,000人参加。
It's an outdoor concert right in the center of what had been the Jewish quarter. And they set up a stage on one end, decorated with menorahs and other Jewish symbols, and it's nationally televised. Polish national television carries this concert live.
这是一场就在曾经的犹太区中心举行的户外音乐会。他们在舞台一端搭设了台子，装饰着灯台和其他犹太符号，并且进行全国直播。波兰国家电视台直播了这场音乐会。
And they bring in klezmer musicians from around the world, the top klezmer musicians in the business. And they put them on stage, and they bring in thousands and thousands of young people, mostly in their 20s, teens, 20s, 30s, and they just pack this square. And they go crazy. It's just like this big rock concert, only it's klezmer music.
他们请来了世界各地的顶级克莱兹默音乐家。他们把他们请上台，吸引了成千上万的年轻人，主要是20多岁、十几岁、30岁的人，把整个广场挤得水泄不通。他们陷入了疯狂。就像一场大型摇滚音乐会，只不过是克莱兹默音乐。
And they're non-Jews. These people in the crowd, just to be clear, are non-Jews.
他们是非犹太人。要说清楚的是，人群中的这些人都是非犹太人。
There might be some tourists there. There's a mix of people. But by and large, this is the youth culture of Krakow. But this concert capped a week of, there were classes on Jewish dancing that drew 200 people to a high school gym, 200 people who really wanted to learn the horah. There were 60 mostly college-aged kids in a workshop on the Yiddish language.
可能有一些游客。人群是混合的。但总的来说，这是克拉科夫的青年文化。但这只是为期一周的活动的压轴戏，还有吸引了200人到高中体育馆学习犹太舞蹈的课程，200人真的很想学会霍拉舞。在依地语研讨会上，还有60名主要是大学年龄的孩子。
Give your best understanding of how this trend came about. How did this happen?
请谈谈你对这种趋势是如何形成的理解。这是怎么发生的？
It was sort of an intellectual thing in the 80s. There was this group of people who were interested in it. And they would have meetings about Jewish culture, and bring in Jewish writers to come speak, or have concerts of Jewish music. But it was a small thing.
这在80年代是一种知识分子风潮。有一群人对它很感兴趣。他们会举办关于犹太文化的会议，请犹太作家来演讲，或者举办犹太音乐会。但这只是小范围的。
And from this group emerged a number of things, such as the first Jewish cultural festival, which actually started as a Jewish film festival in, I think, 1988. And what happened is it was a huge success. They expected a few dozen people. And in fact, a couple hundred came. And it was a full room. And that was 1988.
从这个群体中产生了一些事情，比如第一个犹太文化节，实际上始于1988年的一个犹太电影节。结果非常成功。他们原以为只有几十人参加。实际上，有几百人来了。房间坐满了。那是1988年。
And the following year, communism falls. So suddenly, not only is there interest, but now there's opportunity. And actually, and then the big turning point around 1993, Spielberg comes to make Schindler's List. And suddenly, there's this big American director in Krakow, making a movie.
第二年，共产主义垮台了。所以突然之间，不仅有了兴趣，现在还有了机会。事实上，然后在1993年左右出现了一个大转折，斯皮尔伯格来拍摄《辛德勒的名单》。突然间，一位美国大导演在克拉科夫拍电影。
A movie about the Jews.
一部关于犹太人的电影。
And he's filming it in the Jewish quarter. He turned this little Jewish quarter into the set for his movie. And it was a huge success. And then when the movie comes out, all these people start flocking to this part of town to see where it was that Spielberg made this big movie, Schindler's List.
他就在犹太区取景。他把这个小小的犹太区变成了电影的拍摄地。非常成功。电影上映后，人们开始蜂拥而至这个城镇，看看斯皮尔伯格拍摄那部大片《辛德勒的名单》的地方。
Now, one of the pieces of tape you've brought in that you recorded there is with the owner of a bookshop?
你带来的一段录音是关于一家书店老板的？
Right, right. And he was a guy who had this love of Jewish culture, and he had just opened up this bookshop. And he put Jewish book titles on the shelves. And then one day, this movie gets made, and the whole world changes.
对，对。他是一个热爱犹太文化的人，刚开了这家书店。他在书架上放了犹太书籍。然后有一天，这部电影拍出来了，整个世界都变了。
Here we go. Here's the tape.
开始吧。这是录音。
We should build memorial for Spielberg in the center of this place. Because thanks to Spielberg, we can exist now in better situation. After Spielberg's film, it was a kind of revolution in the mentality of people. You know that premiere of this film was in December, in New York. First days of January, '94, first American tourists visited me in the bookshop. And every day, it was the same.
我们应该在广场中心为斯皮尔伯格建一座纪念碑。因为多亏了斯皮尔伯格，我们现在的情况好多了。在斯皮尔伯格的电影之后，人们的心理发生了一种革命。你知道这部电影在纽约的首映是在12月。1994年1月的前几天，第一批美国游客拜访了我的书店。每天都是如此。
The bookstore started giving tours. First, they wrote a guidebook of where all the places in the movie were. And then the tourists were coming, and the locals would start to come. It wasn't just foreigners. The whole city wanted to come. And Poles who came to visit from other parts of the country would want to come.
书店开始组织旅游团。首先，他们写了一本指南，标出电影中所有的拍摄地点。接着游客来了，当地人也开始来了。不仅是外国人。整个城市的人都想来。从全国各地来访的波兰人也想来。
And actually, it was so successful, before the movie, there was just the bookshop and one cafe, called the Ariel Cafe. After the movie came out, it was such a success, the people who owned the building where the Ariel Cafe was actually evicted the people who had started the cafe.
实际上，它非常成功，在电影上映前，只有书店和一家叫Ariel的咖啡馆。电影上映后，太成功了，拥有Ariel咖啡馆大楼的人竟然驱逐了经营咖啡馆的人。
The Jewish cafe.
那家犹太咖啡馆。
They were kicked out, and he opened his own Ariel Cafe. And they rented the building next door and opened their own Ariel Cafe. So for the better part of the 1990s, you had two Ariels there. And then there was a lawsuit, and one of them subsequently changed its name to the Olive Cafe. Now it's a whole thriving industry. There's actual Jewish gift shops in Krakow, where they sell wood carvings of Jews playing the violin.
他们被赶了出来，房东自己开了Ariel咖啡馆。他们租了隔壁的楼，也开了自己的Ariel咖啡馆。所以90年代的大部分时间里，那里有两个Ariel。后来发生了诉讼，其中一家随后更名为Olive咖啡馆。现在这是一个欣欣向荣的产业。克拉科夫有真正的犹太礼品店，在那里他们出售拉小提琴的犹太人的木雕。
And how are you feeling about this, as a Jew whose family had to flee Poland in the Second World War?
作为一名家人在二战期间被迫逃离波兰的犹太人，你对此有何感想？
Well, at first, I was somewhat offended, actually, on the grounds of, OK, now that we're not here, now they're interested in Jewish culture? And I wondered, well, gosh, are people making money from this? Are they marketing my culture? It's this weird thing.
嗯，起初，我确实有点被冒犯了，因为，好吧，现在我们不在了，他们才对犹太文化感兴趣？我心想，天哪，人们是在靠这个赚钱吗？他们是在营销我的文化吗？这真是一种奇怪的感觉。
I hadn't been appropriated before. So on one hand, you're kind of flattered. And on the other hand, there's just something about it that doesn't sit right.
我以前没有经历过这种文化挪用。所以一方面，你感到有点受宠若惊。另一方面，这其中就是有什么东西让你感觉不对劲。
I wonder if the feeling you're feeling is something that happens to other groups a lot. I would imagine that an older black person visiting the House of Blues, which is, if I understand right, mostly white-owned and white audiences there walking in with a kind of kitschy presentation of black music.
我想知道，你现在的这种感觉是否在其他群体中也很常见。我可以想象一位年长的黑人走进“蓝调之屋”，据我所知，那主要由白人拥有，观众也主要是白人，带着一种对黑人音乐的俗气展示走进去。
I often compared it to Santa Fe. You have a culture that's primarily selling, marketing Native American culture. And it isn't Native Americans necessarily doing the marketing. There may be some involved, but primarily, their culture is being packaged and sold as part of a tour to tourists.
我经常把它比作圣达菲。你有一个主要是销售、营销美洲原住民文化的文化。而且进行营销的未必是美洲原住民。可能有一些人参与其中，但主要是他们的文化被包装并作为旅游项目出售给游客。
Right, after we've driven them off the land.
没错，在我们把他们赶出土地之后。
Exactly.
正是如此。
You brought in another clip of tape from your interviews in Poland, a woman named Eva?
你带来了你在波兰采访的另一段录音，一个叫伊娃的女人？
Yeah, Ewa Nowakowska. She's an English translator. Her perspective on it really reflects the romanticism that this younger generation has. Her grandmother had described for her how beautiful the Jewish culture was and how the Jewish quarter would light up.
对，伊娃·诺瓦科夫斯卡。她是一位英语翻译。她对这件事的看法确实反映了这一代年轻人所具有的浪漫主义。她的祖母向她描述了犹太文化是多么美丽，以及犹太区曾经是如何灯火辉煌。
Here, let's hear that tape.
来，听听那段录音。
I think that there is a strong feeling of regret whenever I just roam along the streets of Kazimierz, of the former Jewish district, because I can realize how many people were just crowding the streets, how many small shops were opened. It was a thriving culture. And my grandmother's sister told me about all the festivals, especially about Shabbat on Saturdays, when she-- she can recall the whole thing. She could just walk along the streets. And she could see the lit windows in which there were the candlesticks, and they started singing all the Jewish songs. And it was very-- even for the Catholics, it was incredible to feel and experience. And then everything perished, everything disappeared.
我想，每当我漫步在卡齐米日的街道，也就是以前的犹太区，我都会有一种强烈的遗憾感，因为我能意识到曾经有多少人挤在街上，有多少小店开着。那是一种蓬勃发展的文化。我祖母的妹妹告诉我所有那些节日，特别是星期六的安息日，当她——她能回忆起这一切。她可以在街上走。她能看到窗户里亮着的烛台，他们开始唱所有的犹太歌曲。这真是——即使是对天主教徒来说，去感受和体验这种氛围也是不可思议的。然后一切都毁灭了，一切都消失了。
And this was this woman who had actually-- she's a poet-- and she had actually written a series of poems as a tribute to the Jewish family that used to live next door to her grandmother. And she has her grandmother's old diary, and the Jewish family that lived next door had written some Hebrew letters in the book or something. And she talks about it in these romantic terms as this is this last relic, this last holdover, the last thing we have from this family. Whether or not that's true, whether or not that family even survived, we don't necessarily know.
这就是那个女人，她是一位诗人——她实际上写了一系列诗歌，以纪念曾经住在她祖母隔壁的犹太家庭。她保存着她祖母的旧日记，那个隔壁的犹太家庭在书里写了一些希伯来字母之类的东西。她用这种浪漫的口吻谈论它，说这是最后的遗迹，最后的留存，是我们从那个家庭得到的最后的东西。无论事实是否如此，无论那个家庭是否幸存，我们都不一定知道。
So for her, does Jewishness connote a simpler, more innocent time?
所以对她来说，犹太属性暗示了一个更简单、更纯真的时代吗？
I think probably, yes.
我想很可能是的。
And how strange that the time that it connotes is 1930s eastern Europe.
多么奇怪啊，它所暗示的时代竟然是20世纪30年代的东欧。
But you always have a romantic idea of what life was before you experienced it. And what was in Poland at that time, but Jews? It's something from the past. It's something magical and mystical.
但在你真正体验之前，你总是会对生活有一种浪漫的想法。那个时期的波兰除了犹太人还能有什么？这是一种过去的东西。它是一种魔法般的、神秘的东西。
It's funny how being gone can make it magical and mystical.
很有趣，一个人不在了，反而会让它变得充满魔法和神秘色彩。
Yeah. And that's why these Jewish-themed cafes are all designed like 19th-century living rooms. They used old, white, lace tablecloths and antique furniture and antique frames on the portraits on the walls. It's got a poignant, melodramatic flair to it that the artistic types are drawn to.
是的。这就是为什么这些犹太主题咖啡馆的设计都像是19世纪的客厅。他们使用了陈旧的白色蕾丝桌布、古董家具和墙上肖像画的古董框架。它带有一种艺术类型的人所向往的凄美、夸张的情调。
Was it just that the people who you were getting to know were fascinated by Jewish culture, or were they actually looking for their own Jewish roots? Was there a sense of, oh, maybe I'm part Jewish?
仅仅是因为你结识的人对犹太文化着迷吗，还是说他们真的在寻找自己的犹太血统？有没有一种感觉，噢，也许我有一部分犹太血统？
There is an absolute trend among certain young Poles to go try and find the Jewish ancestor in the closet. If you actually find a Jewish relative, it's something that distinguishes you from everybody else. Not only is the country largely homogeneous ethnically, but under communism, there were restricted colors of paint and restricted kinds of architecture. And everybody had the same sort of job and the same sort of house and the same sort of life. And it was all very same and really bland.
在某些波兰年轻人中，绝对存在一种试图去寻找“壁橱里的犹太祖先”的趋势。如果你真的能找到一位犹太亲戚，那是一件让你与众不同的事情。不仅这个国家在种族上基本同质，而且在共产主义下，油漆颜色和建筑风格都是受限制的。每个人都有同样的工作、同样的房子、同样的生活。这一切都非常千篇一律，真的很平淡。
And this young culture wants to try and distinguish themselves from the previous generations, and try and show we're different. We're Western, we're capitalistic, I don't know, ethnically different. And so if you can actually prove that you are, in fact, ethnically different, well, that's taking it to the next level.
而这种年轻文化想要努力与前几代人区分开来，想要展示我们是不一样的。我们是西方的，资本主义的，我不知道，种族上是不同的。所以如果你能证明你确实在种族上与众不同，好吧，那真是更上一层楼了。
So as somebody who actually is Jewish, when you would explain to people that you're actually Jewish, was it suddenly like you were a celebrity?
所以作为一名真正的犹太人，当你向人们解释你其实是犹太人时，感觉就像你是位名人吗？
I don't think I was a celebrity, but it was like I just told them I came back from Mars. They want to hear everything about it. And actually, one of the things I think I said I heard all the time, people would hear I was a Jew. I'd be at a party. I would tell them what I was doing in Poland. And they'd say, "Oh my God. Wow. Really? You're a Jew? Wow, that's so exciting. My grandmother's best friend was a Jew." It's like every Polish grandmother had a Jew for a best friend.
我不觉得我是名人，但这感觉就像我刚刚告诉他们我从火星回来一样。他们想听关于它的一切。事实上，我想我一直听到的事情之一是，人们听说我是犹太人。我会在派对上。我会告诉他们我在波兰做什么。他们会说：“噢，我的天。哇。真的吗？你是犹太人？哇，那太令人激动了。我祖母最好的朋友就是犹太人。”就像每位波兰祖母都有个犹太好朋友一样。
That's such a weird variation on "some of my best friends are Jewish." "Some of my grandmother's best friends were Jewish."
这真是一种对“我最好的朋友中有一些是犹太人”的奇怪变体。“我祖母最好的朋友中就有犹太人。”
And it could be legitimate because their grandmothers were children just before the war. And especially if they were in a place like Krakow, which was urban and educated, there were lots and lots of Jews. The schools were integrated. Yeah, maybe. Maybe they aren't lying or-- and they tell their grandchildren about it.
这也可能是真的，因为他们的祖母在战前还是孩子。特别是如果她们生活在克拉科夫这样的城市且受过教育的地方，那里有很多很多犹太人。学校是融合的。也许吧。也许他们没在撒谎——他们把这些告诉了孙辈。
When you never meet a Jew, you never have a problem with a Jew. You never have a conflict. And all the things that may or may not have threatened their grandparents or their great-grandparents or the things that may have defined several hundred years of Polish-Jewish relations are moot. All they have is the romance, and the memory, and none of the things that create problems.
当你从没见过犹太人，你就从没跟犹太人发生过矛盾。你从没发生过冲突。而那些可能威胁到他们祖父母或曾祖父母的事情，或者是那些可能定义了波兰与犹太人几百年关系的事情，现在都变得无关紧要了。他们所拥有的只有浪漫和记忆，而没有那些制造麻烦的东西。
Do you think it's possible for Poles to honor Jews in a way that wouldn't feel a little bit creepy or disturbing to Jews?
你认为波兰人有可能以一种不会让犹太人感到有点毛骨悚然或不安的方式来纪念犹太人吗？
Yeah, I think I do have this suspicion, I guess, that I can't seem to get past. When people would come up to me and say, "Oh, yeah, my grandmother's best friend was a Jew," there's this part of me that would want to say, "Yeah? And what did Grandma do when they came to take away her friend?" Granted, Grandma was a nine-year-old girl, so she did nothing.
是的，我想我确实有这种怀疑，我想我无法摆脱。当人们走过来对我说：“噢，是的，我祖母最好的朋友是犹太人”时，我内心有一部分会想说：“是吗？当他们要把她的朋友带走时，奶奶做了什么？”当然，奶奶当时是个九岁的小女孩，所以她什么也没做。
I wish I could view it not cynically. I wish that I were that open-minded and not so biased and prejudicial. But I'm a product of my own history.
我希望我能不那么愤世嫉俗地看待它。我希望我能思想开放，不那么偏执和带有偏见。但我本身就是我自己历史的产物。
And my mother had this crazy-- she had five mothers by the time she was nine because she was tossed around. And my grandmother was killed. And my grandfather was in Auschwitz. So you just can't set aside that context and that history, as much as you can try.
我母亲有那种疯狂的经历——她在九岁之前就有五个母亲，因为她被到处转送。我祖母被杀了。我祖父在奥斯威辛。所以你无法抛开那个背景和那段历史，尽管你可以尝试。
Erin Einhorn is a reporter for the New York Daily News. She's finished her book about the family that hid her mother from the Holocaust, and she's looking for a publisher. The family, it turns out, did not just do it for the money. One of them burst into tears when Erin showed up at his door. Coming up, when your trivet does the talking, and you get ignored, and David Sedaris on love. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
艾琳·艾因霍恩是《纽约每日新闻》的记者。她写完了关于那个在二战中隐藏她母亲免遭大屠杀的家庭的书，正在寻找出版商。事实证明，这个家庭并不仅仅是为了钱。当艾琳出现在他的门口时，其中一个人热泪盈眶。接下来，当你的隔热垫在说话，而你被忽视时，以及大卫·塞达里斯谈论爱情。从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台，我们节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Fake ID, an idea so simple, a theme so simple that, for a change, I do not have to explain it. We have arrived at act two of our program, Act Two, This Blessed House. In this act, we bring you a piece of short fiction from Jhumpa Lahiri, a story whose similarities to Erin's story about Poland will become all too clear. Mira Nair reads this story for us.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目，“假身份”，一个如此简单的主题，简单到我甚至不需要解释它。我们进入节目的第二幕，“这个受祝福的家”。在这一幕中，我们为您带来Jhumpa Lahiri的一篇短篇小说，这个故事与艾琳关于波兰的故事之间的相似之处将变得非常清晰。米拉·奈尔为我们阅读了这个故事。
They discovered the first one in a cupboard above the stove, beside an unopened bottle of malt vinegar. "Guess what I found?" Twinkle walked into the living room, lined from end to end with taped-up packing boxes, waving the vinegar in one hand and a white porcelain effigy of Christ, roughly the same size as the vinegar bottle, in the other.
他们在炉子上方的一个橱柜里，在一瓶未开封的麦芽醋旁边发现了第一个。“猜猜我发现了什么？”特温克尔走进客厅，房间里排满了贴着胶带的包装箱，一只手挥舞着醋瓶，另一只手拿着一个白色的瓷制基督像，大小和醋瓶差不多。
Sanjeev looked up. He was kneeling on the floor, marking, with ripped bits of a Post-it, patches on the baseboard that needed to be retouched with paint. "Throw it away." "Which?" she said. "Both."
桑杰夫抬起头。他正跪在地上，用撕下的便利贴碎片标记着底板上需要重新补漆的地方。“把它扔掉。”“扔哪个？”她说。“两个都扔。”
"But I can cook something with the vinegar. It's brand new." "You've never cooked anything with vinegar." "I'll look something up in one of those books we got for our wedding." Sanjeev turned back to the baseboard to replace a Post-it strap that had fallen to the floor. "Check the expiration, and at the very least, get rid of that idiotic statue." "But it could be worth something, who knows?"
“但我可以用这醋做饭啊。它是全新的。”“你从来没用过醋做饭。”“我会在我们结婚时收到的那些书里查查。”桑杰夫转过身继续去处理底板，更换掉落到地上的便利贴条。“检查一下保质期，至少把那个愚蠢的雕像扔掉。”“但它可能值点钱，谁知道呢？”
She turned it upside down, then stroked with her index finger the minuscule, frozen folds of its robes. "It's pretty." "We're not Christian," Sanjeev said. Lately, he had begun noticing the need to state the obvious to Twinkle. The day before, he had to tell her that if she dragged her end of the bureau, instead of lifting it, the parquet floor would scratch.
她把它倒过来，然后用食指轻轻抚摸着它长袍上微小的、凝固的褶皱。“它很漂亮。”“我们不是基督徒，”桑杰夫说。最近，他开始发现有必要对特温克尔说一些显而易见的话。前一天，他不得不告诉她，如果她拖着五斗橱的那一端走，而不是抬起来，拼花地板就会被刮伤。
She shrugged. "No, we're not Christian. We're good little Hindus." She planted a kiss on top of Christ's head, then placed the statue on top of the fireplace mantle, which needed, Sanjeev observed, to be dusted.
她耸了耸肩。“不，我们不是基督徒。我们是好的印度教徒。”她在基督头的顶部吻了一下，然后把雕像放在了壁炉台面上，桑杰夫注意到那上面需要掸掸灰尘了。
By the end of the week, the mantle had still not been dusted. It had, however, come to serve as the display shelf for a sizable collection of Christian paraphernalia. There was a 3-D postcard of Saint Francis done in four colors, which Twinkle had found taped to the back of the medicine cabinet, and a wooden cross keychain which Sanjeev had stepped on with bare feet as he was installing extra shelving in Twinkle's study. There was a framed paint-by-number of the three wise men against a black velvet background tucked in the linen closet. There was also a tile trivet depicting a blond, unbearded Jesus delivering a sermon on a mountaintop left in one of the drawers of the built-in china cabinet in the dining room.
到周末结束时，台面还是没掸灰。然而，它却成了各种基督徒小物件的大型陈列架。有一个特温克尔在药柜后面发现的四色圣方济各3D明信片，还有一个木制十字架钥匙链，桑杰夫在特温克尔的书房安装额外的架子时，光着脚踩在了上面。在亚麻布柜里藏着一幅以黑色天鹅绒为背景的数字油画，画着三位智者。在餐厅内置中式橱柜的一个抽屉里，还留着一块瓷砖隔热垫，上面描绘着一个金发、没留胡子的耶稣在山顶上布道。
"Do you think the previous owners were born-agains?" asked Twinkle, making room the next day for a small, plastic snow-filled dome, containing a miniature nativity scene, found behind the pipes of the kitchen sink. Sanjeev was organizing his engineering texts from MIT in alphabetical order on a bookshelf, though it had been several years since he had needed to consult any of them. At 33, he had a secretary of his own and a dozen people working under his supervision who gladly supplied him with any information he needed. Still, the presence of his college books in the room reminded him of a time in his life he recalled with fondness, when he would walk each evening across the Mass Avenue bridge to order Mughlai chicken with spinach from his favorite Indian restaurant on the other side of the Charles and return to his dorm room to write out clean copies of his problem sets.
“你觉得前房主是重生基督徒吗？”特温克尔第二天问道，她正在为一个小小的塑料圆顶挪地方，里面装着一个在厨房水槽水管后面发现的微型耶稣诞生场景。桑杰夫正在书架上按字母顺序整理他从麻省理工学院毕业时的工程教材，尽管他已经好几年不需要查阅其中的任何一本了。33岁时，他有了自己的秘书，手下有十几个人工作，他们乐意为他提供他需要的任何信息。不过，他在房间里看到的这些大学书籍提醒了他一段他怀念的时光，那时他每天晚上都要走过马萨诸塞大道桥，去查尔斯河对岸他最喜欢的印度餐馆点一份玛莎拉菠菜鸡，然后回到宿舍写下干净的习题作业副本。
"Or perhaps it's an attempt to convert people," Twinkle mused. "Clearly, the scheme has succeeded in your case," Sanjeev said. She disregarded him, shaking the little plastic dome so that the snow swirled over the manger.
“或者这可能是一种试图转化人们的尝试，”特温克尔若有所思地说。“显然，这个计划在你身上成功了，”桑杰夫说。她没理会他，摇晃着那个小塑料圆顶，让雪花在马槽上方飞舞。
Sanjeev studied the items on the mantle. It puzzled him that each was, in its own way, so silly. Clearly, they lacked a sense of sacredness. He was further puzzled that Twinkle, who normally displayed good taste, was so charmed. These objects meant something to Twinkle, but they meant nothing to him. They irritated him.
桑杰夫研究着台面上的物品。令他困惑的是，每一个都显得那么愚蠢。显然，它们缺乏一种神圣感。更让他困惑的是，一向品味不错的特温克尔竟然会被这些东西迷住。这些物件对特温克尔有意义，对他来说却毫无意义。它们让他恼火。
"We should call the realtor, tell them there's all this nonsense left behind. Tell him to take it away." "Oh, Sanj," Twinkle groaned. "Please, I would feel terrible throwing them away. Obviously, they were important to the people who used to live here. It would feel, I don't know, I mean, sacrilegious or something?"
“我们应该给房地产中介打电话，告诉他们还有这些乱七八糟的东西留下来。告诉他把它带走。”“噢，桑杰，”特温克尔呻吟道。“拜托，扔掉它们我会觉得很难过。显然，它们对以前住在这里的人很重要。这样做会显得，我不知道，我的意思是，亵渎神明之类的？”
"If they're so precious, then why were they hidden all over the house? Why didn't they take them with them?" "There must be others," Twinkle said. Her eyes roamed the bare, off-white walls of the room, as if there were other things concealed behind the plaster. "What else do you think we'll find?"
“如果它们那么珍贵，为什么它们被藏在房子的各个角落？为什么他们不带走？”“肯定还有别的，”特温克尔说。她的目光扫视着房间里光秃秃的灰白色墙壁，仿佛石膏后面还藏着别的东西。“你觉得我们还会发现什么？”
Nearly a week had passed before they discovered, one Saturday afternoon, a larger than life-sized watercolor poster of Christ, weeping translucent tears the size of peanut shells and sporting a crown of thorns, rolled up behind a radiator in the guest bedroom. Sanjeev had mistaken it for a window shade. "Oh, we must, we simply must put it up. It's too spectacular." Twinkle lit a cigarette and began to smoke it with relish, waving it around Sanjeev's head as if it were a conductor's baton, as Mahler's Fifth Symphony roared from the stereo downstairs.
几乎过了一个星期，他们在一个周六下午发现了一张比真人还大的基督水彩海报，基督流着花生壳大小的透明泪水，带着荆棘冠，卷在客房的散热器后面。桑杰夫把它误认为是窗帘。“噢，我们必须，我们一定要把它挂起来。它太壮观了。”特温克尔点了一支烟，津津有味地抽着，像指挥棒一样在桑杰夫头顶挥舞，楼下的音响里咆哮着马勒第五交响曲。
"Now look, I will tolerate for now your little Biblical menagerie in the living room. But I refuse to have this," he said, flicking at one of the painted peanut tears, "displayed in our home." Twinkle stared at him, the smoke emerging in two thin, blue streams from her nostrils. She rolled up the poster slowly, securing it with one of the elastic bands she always wore around her wrist for tying back her thick, unruly hair, streaked here and there with henna. "I'm going to put it in my study," she informed him. "That way, you don't have to look at it."
“现在听着，我暂时可以容忍你在客厅里的那些小圣经珍品。但我拒绝让这个，”他说着，弹了一下其中一颗彩绘的花生泪水，“出现在我们的家里。”特温克尔盯着他，烟从她的鼻孔中冒出两缕细细的蓝色烟流。她慢慢卷起海报，用她总是戴在手腕上用来系她浓密、凌乱头发的一根橡皮筋固定住，头发上还杂乱地染着指甲花。她通知他：“我要把它放在我的书房里。那样你就不用看了。”
"What about the housewarming? They'll want to see all the rooms. I've invited people from the office." She rolled her eyes. Sanjeev noted that the symphony on the stereo, now in its third movement, had reached a crescendo, for it pulsed with the telltale clashing of cymbals.
“暖房派对怎么办？他们会想参观所有的房间。我邀请了办公室的人。”她翻了个白眼。桑杰夫注意到楼下音响里的交响曲已经进入第三乐章，达到了高潮，因为里面伴随着明显的钹声碰撞。
"I'll put it behind the door," she offered. "That way, when they peek in, they won't see. Happy?" Sanjeev stood watching her as she left the room with her poster and her cigarette. A few ashes had fallen to the floor where she'd been standing. He bent down, pinched them between his fingers, and deposited them in his cupped palm.
“我会把它放在门后，”她提议道。“那样，当他们偷看时，就不会看到了。高兴了吧？”桑杰夫站在那里看着她带着海报和烟离开房间。一些烟灰落在了她站过的地方。他弯下腰，用指尖捻起它们，放进合拢的手掌里。
On the stereo downstairs, the tender fourth movement, the adagietto, began. During breakfast, Sanjeev had read in the liner notes that Mahler had proposed to his wife by sending her the manuscript of this portion of the score. Although there were elements of tragedy and struggle in the Fifth Symphony, he had read, it was principally music of love and happiness. He heard the toilet flush. "By the way," Twinkle hollered, "if you want to impress people, I wouldn't play this music. It's putting me to sleep."
楼下的音响里，温柔的第四乐章，柔板，开始了。早餐时，桑杰夫在唱片封套说明里读到，马勒是通过把这一部分的乐谱手稿寄给妻子而向她求婚的。他读到，尽管第五交响曲中有悲剧和挣扎的元素，但它主要是关于爱和幸福的音乐。他听到马桶冲水声。“顺便说一下，”特温克尔喊道，“如果你想给人们留下好印象，我不会放这种音乐。这让我困得很。”
A few days later, when Sanjeev returned from the office, he smelled something aromatic on the stove. He opened the lid of the pot with some sort of reddish-brown sauce dripping over the sides, boiling furiously. "It's a stew made with fish. I put the vinegar in it," she said, crossing her fingers.
几天后，桑杰夫从办公室回来时，闻到炉子上有什么香气。他打开锅盖，某种红褐色的酱汁顺着边缘滴下来，煮得正欢。“这是一个用鱼做的炖菜。我放了麦芽醋在里面，”她说，交叉着手指。
She was like that, excited and delighted by little things, crossing her fingers before any remotely unpredictable event, like tasting a new flavor of ice cream or dropping a letter in the mailbox. It was a quality he did not understand. It made him feel stupid, as if the world contained hidden wonders he could not anticipate or see.
她就是那样，会被小事所吸引和高兴，在任何稍微不可预测的事情发生之前都会交叉手指，比如品尝一种新口味的冰淇淋或把信扔进邮箱。这是他无法理解的一种品质。这让他觉得自己很愚蠢，仿佛这个世界隐藏着他无法预见或看到的奇迹。
They had met only four months before. Her parents, who lived in California, and his, who lived in Calcutta, were old friends. And across continents, they had arranged the occasion at which Twinkle and Sanjeev were introduced, a 16th birthday party for a daughter in their circle, when Sanjeev was in Palo Alto on business.
他们四个月前才认识。她的父母住在加州，他的父母住在加尔各答，是老朋友了。跨越洲际，他们安排了特温克尔和桑杰夫相亲的场合，当时桑杰夫在帕洛阿尔托出差，参加他们圈子里一个女儿的16岁生日派对。
At the restaurant, they were seated side by side at a round table, with a revolving platter of spare ribs and egg rolls and chicken wings, which they concurred all tasted the same. They had concurred, too, on their adolescent, but still persistent fondness for Wodehouse novels and their dislike for the sitar. And later, Twinkle confessed, she was charmed by the way Sanjeev had dutifully refilled her teacup during their conversation.
在餐厅里，他们坐在圆桌旁，桌上有一个旋转盘，上面放着排骨、蛋卷和鸡翅，他们一致认为所有东西尝起来都一样。他们还一致同意他们对伍德豪斯小说的少年时代但仍持续的喜爱，以及对锡塔尔琴的厌恶。后来，特温克尔承认，她被桑杰夫在谈话中尽职尽责地为她续茶的方式所吸引。
And so the phone calls began and grew longer. And then the visits, first he to Stanford, then she to Connecticut, after which Sanjeev would save in an ashtray left on the balcony the crushed cigarettes she had smoked during the weekend, saved them, that is, until the next time she came to visit him. And then he vacuumed the apartment, washed the sheets, even dusted the plant leaves in her honor.
于是电话开始变多，通话时间也越来越长。然后是探访，先是他去斯坦福，然后是她去康涅狄格州，之后桑杰夫会把她周末抽过的烟蒂保存在阳台的烟灰缸里，保存到她下次来看他。然后他为她打扫公寓，换床单，甚至为她擦拭植物叶子上的灰尘。
She was 27 and recently abandoned, he had gathered, by an American who had tried and failed to be an actor. Sanjeev was lonely, with an excessively generous income for a single man, and had never been in love. At the urging of their matchmakers, they married in India amid hundreds of well wishers whom he barely remembered from his childhood, in incessant August rains, under a red and orange tent strung with Christmas tree lights on Mandeville Road.
她27岁，最近被一个想当演员却失败了的美国人抛弃了。桑杰夫很孤独，作为一个单身汉，他收入优渥，但从未谈过恋爱。在媒人的催促下，他们在印度结婚了，在曼德维尔路，在红橙色的帐篷下，挂满了圣诞灯饰，在不停的八月雨中，身边有成百上千他童年时几乎记不清的祝福者。
"Did you sweep the attic?" he asked Twinkle later, as she was folding paper napkins and wedging them by their plates. The attic was the only part of the house they had not yet given an initial cleaning. "Not yet. I will, I promise. I hope this tastes good," she said, planting the steaming pot on top of the Jesus trivet. There was a loaf of Italian bread in a little basket, and iceberg lettuce and grated carrots tossed with bottled dressing and croutons, and glasses of red wine. She was not terribly ambitious in the kitchen.
“你打扫阁楼了吗？”桑杰夫后来问特温克尔，当时她正在折叠纸巾并塞在盘子旁边。阁楼是他们房子唯一还没有进行初步清理的地方。“还没有。我会的，我保证。希望这东西味道不错，”她说，把冒着热气的锅放在了那个耶稣隔热垫上面。小篮子里放着一条意大利面包，还有卷心莴苣和磨碎的胡萝卜，拌着瓶装酱汁和面包丁，还有几杯红酒。她在厨房里并不是特别有野心。
She bought pre-roasted chickens from the supermarket and served them with potato salad prepared who knew when, sold in little plastic containers. Indian food, she complained, was a bother. She detested chopping garlic and peeling ginger, and could not operate a blender, and so it was Sanjeev who, on weekends, seasoned mustard oil with cinnamon sticks and cloves in order to produce a proper curry.
她从超市买来现烤的鸡肉，配上不知道什么时候做好的土豆沙拉，装在小塑料盒子里出售。她抱怨说，做印度菜很麻烦。她讨厌切大蒜和剥姜，也不会用搅拌机，所以周末都是桑杰夫用肉桂棒和丁香将芥末油调味，才做出正宗的咖喱。
He had to admit, though, that whatever it was that she had cooked today, it was unusually tasty. "How did you make it?" "I just put some things into the pot and added the malt vinegar at the end." "How much vinegar?" She shrugged, ripping off some bread and plunging it into her bowl. "What do you mean you don't know? You should write it down. What if you need to make it again for a party or something?" "I'll remember," she said.
不过他不得不承认，无论她今天煮的是什么，味道都格外好。“你是怎么做的？”“我只是往锅里扔了些东西，最后加了麦芽醋。”“加了多少醋？”她耸了耸肩，撕下一块面包，埋进碗里。“你什么意思你不知道？你应该写下来的。如果你需要为了派对什么的再做一遍怎么办？”“我会记住的，”她说。
She covered the bread basket with a dish towel that had, he suddenly noticed, the Ten Commandments printed on it. She flashed him a smile, giving his knee a little squeeze under the table. "Face it. This house is blessed."
她用一块洗碗巾盖住面包篮，他突然注意到上面印着“十诫”。她对他露出一抹微笑，在桌下轻轻挤了挤他的膝盖。“面对现实吧。这个家是有福的。”
The housewarming party was scheduled for the last Saturday in October, and they had invited about 30 people. All were Sanjeev's acquaintances, people from the office and a number of Indian couples in the Connecticut area, many of whom he barely knew, but who had regularly invited him, in his bachelor days, to supper on Saturdays.
暖房派对定在10月的最后一个星期六，他们邀请了大约30个人。全都是桑杰夫的熟人，来自办公室的人和康涅狄格州的一些印度夫妇，其中许多人他几乎不认识，但在他单身的日子里，他们曾定期邀请他周六去吃晚饭。
So far, no one had met Twinkle. Back when they were still dating, Sanjeev didn't want to waste their brief weekends together with people he associated with being alone. Other than Sanjeev and an ex-boyfriend, who she believed worked in a pottery studio in Brookfield, she knew no one in the state of Connecticut. She was completing her Master's thesis at Stanford, a study of an Irish poet whom Sanjeev had never heard of.
到目前为止，还没有人见过特温克尔。当他们还在约会时，桑杰夫不想浪费他们在一起短暂的周末去见那些他与孤独联系在一起的人。除了桑杰夫和一个前男友，她认为他是在布鲁克菲尔德的一家陶艺工作室工作，她在康涅狄格州谁也不认识。她当时正在斯坦福完成硕士论文，研究一位桑杰夫从未听说过的爱尔兰诗人。
The weekend before the party, they were raking the lawn when Sanjeev heard Twinkle shriek. He ran to her, clutching his rake, worried that she had discovered a dead animal or a snake. A brisk October breeze stung the top of his ears as his sneakers crunched over brown and yellow leaves.
派对的前一个周末，他们正在扫草坪，桑杰夫听到特温克尔尖叫。他紧抓着耙子跑向她，担心她发现了死动物或蛇。清脆的十月微风刺痛了他的耳尖，他的运动鞋在褐色和黄色的落叶上嘎吱作响。
When he reached her, she had collapsed on the grass, dissolved in nearly silent laughter. Behind an overgrown forsythia bush was a plaster Virgin Mary as tall as their waists, with a blue painted hood draped over her head in the manner of an Indian bride. Twinkle grabbed the hem of her t-shirt and began wiping away the dirt staining the statue's brow.
当他跑到她身边时，她已经瘫倒在草地上，沉浸在近乎无声的笑声中。在一丛杂乱的连翘灌木后，是一个腰部高低的石膏圣母玛利亚像，头上披着蓝色的油漆头巾，就像一位印度新娘。特温克尔抓住她T恤的下摆，开始擦拭污垢圣像眉毛上的污渍。
"I suppose you'll want to put her by the foot of our bed," Sanjeev said. She looked at him astonished. "No, silly Sanj. This is meant for outside, for the lawn." "Twinkle, no, all the neighbors will see. They'll think we're insane." "Why? For having a statue of the Virgin Mary on our lawn? Every other person in this neighborhood has a statue of Virgin Mary on the lawn. We'll fit right in."
“我想你会想把她放在我们床脚的，”桑杰夫说。她惊讶地看着他。“不，傻桑杰。这是为了放在外面，放在草坪上的。”“特温克尔，不，所有的邻居都会看到的。他们会以为我们疯了。”“为什么？因为在草坪上放一个圣母玛利亚像？这个社区里的每个人都在草坪上放圣母玛利亚像。我们会很合群的。”
"We're not Christian." "So you keep reminding me." She spat onto the top of her finger and started to rub intently at a particularly stubborn stain on Mary's chin. He was getting nowhere with her, with this woman whom he had known for only four months, and whom he had married, this woman with whom he now shared his life. He thought, with a flicker of regret, of the snapshots his mother used to send him from Calcutta of prospective brides who could sing and sew and season lentils without consulting a cookbook. Sanjeev had considered these women, had even ranked them in order of preference. But then he had met Twinkle.
“我们不是基督徒。”“你一直在提醒我。”她往指尖上吐了口唾沫，开始用力擦拭玛丽下巴上一块特别顽固的污渍。他对她一点办法都没有，这个他只认识四个月就娶了的女人，这个现在和他分享生活的女人。他带着一丝悔意想到了他母亲从加尔各答寄给他的快照，上面是那些能唱歌、能缝纫、不用看食谱就能调味扁豆的潜在新娘。桑杰夫考虑过这些女人，甚至按偏好对她们排过名。但后来他遇到了特温克尔。
"Twinkle, I can't have the people I work with see this statue on my lawn." "Why does it matter to you so much what other people think?" "Twinkle, please." He let his weight rest against his rake as she began dragging the statue toward an oval bed of myrtle beside the lamppost that flanked the brick pathway. "Look, Sanj, she's so lovely."
“特温克尔，我不能让我一起工作的人看到我家草坪上有这个雕像。”“别人怎么想对你就那么重要吗？”“特温克尔，拜托。”他把重量靠在耙子上，她开始把雕像拖向灯柱旁边的一片圆形的桃金娘花圃，灯柱就在砖道边上。“看，桑杰，她太可爱了。”
He returned to his pile of leaves and began to deposit them by handfuls into a plastic garbage bag. Over his head, the blue sky was cloudless. One tree on the lawn was still full of leaves, red and orange, like the tent in which he had married Twinkle.
他回到他的落叶堆，开始一把一把地放进塑料垃圾袋。在他头顶上，蓝色的天空万里无云。草坪上的一棵树依然挂满了落叶，红色和橙色，就像他娶特温克尔时用的那个帐篷。
He did not know if he loved her. He said he did when she had first asked him, one afternoon in Palo Alto, as they sat side by side in a darkened, nearly empty movie theater. Before the film, one of her favorites, something in German that he found extremely depressing, she had pressed the tip of her nose to his, so that he could feel the flutter of her mascara-coated eyelashes. That afternoon, he had replied, yes, he loved her. And she was delighted and fed him a piece of popcorn, letting her finger linger an instant between his lips, as if it were his reward for coming up with the right answer.
他不知道自己是否爱她。当她在帕洛阿尔托，他们坐在黑暗、几乎空无一人的电影院里，第一次问他时，他说他爱她。在电影之前，那是她最喜欢的电影之一，某种他觉得极其压抑的德语电影，她把鼻尖紧紧贴在他鼻子上，让他能感觉到她刷了睫毛膏的睫毛的颤动。那天下午，他回答说，是的，他爱她。她很高兴，喂了他一颗爆米花，让她的手指在他嘴唇间停留了一会儿，仿佛那是他给出正确答案的奖励。
Though she did not say it herself, he assumed then that she loved him too. But now he was no longer sure. In truth, Sanjeev did not know what love was, only what he thought it was not.
虽然她自己没说，但他当时认定她也爱他。但现在他不再确定了。事实上，桑杰夫不知道什么是爱，只知道他认为什么不是爱。
It was not, he decided, returning to an empty carpeted condominium each night and using only the top fork in his cutlery drawer, and turning away politely at those weekend dinner parties when the other men eventually put their arms around the waists of their wives and girlfriends, leaning over every now and again to kiss their shoulders or necks. It was not sending away for classical music CDs by mail, working his way methodically through the major composers that the catalog recommended, and always sending his payments in on time.
他断定，这不是每天晚上回到一个空荡荡、铺着地毯的公寓，餐具抽屉里只用最上面的叉子，在周末晚宴上，当其他男人最终搂住妻子和女朋友的腰，并不时弯下腰吻她们的肩膀或脖子时，他只能礼貌地转过头去。这不是通过邮件预订古典音乐CD，有条不紊地研究目录推荐的作曲家，并且总是准时支付费用。
In the months before meeting Twinkle, Sanjeev had begun to realize this. "You have enough money in the bank to raise three families," his mother reminded him when they spoke at the start of each month on the phone. "You need a wife to look after and love." Now he had one, a pretty one, from a suitably high caste, who would soon have a Master's degree. What was there not to love?
在遇到特温克尔前的几个月里，桑杰夫开始意识到这一点。“你银行里的钱够养三个家庭的，”他母亲每月初在电话里提醒他。“你需要一个妻子来照顾和爱护。”现在他有了，一个漂亮的，来自适当高种姓的，很快就会有硕士学位的女人。有什么是不值得爱的呢？
The menu for the party was fairly simple. There would be a case of champagne and samosas from an Indian restaurant in Hartford, and big trays of rice with chicken and almonds and orange peels, which Sanjeev had spent the greater part of the morning and afternoon preparing. He had never entertained on such a large scale before. And, worried that there would not be enough to drink, ran out at one point to buy another case of champagne just in case.
派对的菜单相当简单。会有几箱香槟和来自哈特福德一家印度餐馆的萨莫萨三角饺，以及几大盘配有鸡肉、杏仁和橙皮的米饭，那是桑杰夫花了大半个上午和下午准备的。他以前从未如此大规模地招待客人。担心酒水不够，有一次还跑出去多买了一箱香槟以防万一。
Twinkle swept the floors and volunteered to pick up the samosas. She had an appointment for a manicure and pedicure in that direction anyway. Sanjeev had planned to ask if she would consider cleaning the menagerie off the mantle, if only for the party. But she left while he was in the shower.
特温克尔打扫了地板，并自告奋勇去拿萨莫萨三角饺。她刚好要去那个方向做美甲和足疗。桑杰夫本打算问她是否考虑把壁炉台面上的珍品清理掉，哪怕只是为了派对。但她在他洗澡的时候就离开了。
She was gone for a good three hours, and so it was Sanjeev who did the rest of the cleaning. By 5:30, the entire house sparkled, with scented candles that Twinkle had picked up in Hartford illuminating the items on the mantle, and slender stalks of burning incense planted into the soil of potted plants. Each time he passed the mantle, he winced, dreading the raised eyebrows of his guests as they viewed the flickering ceramic saints, the salt and pepper shakers designed to resemble Mary and Joseph.
她走了整整三个小时，所以剩下的清理工作都是桑杰夫做的。到5:30时，整个房子闪闪发光，特温克尔从哈特福德买来的香薰蜡烛照亮了台面上的物品，盆栽植物的土里插着细长的燃烧的香。每次经过台面时，他都会畏缩，担心客人看到那些摇曳的陶瓷圣徒、设计成玛丽和约瑟夫形状的盐胡椒瓶时会挑起眉头。
Douglas, one of the new consultants at the firm, and his girlfriend Nora were the first to arrive. Both were tall and blond, wearing matching wire-rimmed glasses and long, black overcoats. Nora wore a black hat full of sharp, thin feathers that corresponded to the sharp, thin angles of her face. Her left hand was joined with Douglas's. In her right hand was a bottle of cognac with a red ribbon wrapped around its neck, which she gave to Twinkle.
道格拉斯，公司新来的顾问之一，还有他的女朋友诺拉是第一批到达的。两人都身材高大，金发，戴着相配的金丝边眼镜，穿着长长的黑色大衣。诺拉戴着一顶满是尖尖细羽毛的黑帽子，与她脸上尖锐、细长的角度相对应。她的左手牵着道格拉斯的。右手拿着一瓶颈部缠着红丝带的干邑白兰地，她把它给了特温克尔。
"Great lawn, Sanjeev," Douglas remarked. "We've got to get that rake out ourselves, sweetie. And this must be?" "My wife, Tanima." "Call me Twinkle." "What an unusual name," Nora remarked. "Pleased to meet you, Twinkle." "Help yourself to champagne," Twinkle said. "There's gallons."
“棒极了的草坪，桑杰夫，”道格拉斯评论道。“我们自己得把那个耙子收起来，亲爱的。这一定是？”“我的妻子，塔尼玛。”“叫我特温克尔就行。”“多么不寻常的名字，”诺拉评论道。“很高兴见到你，特温克尔。”“随便喝香槟，”特温克尔说。“有几加仑呢。”
"I hope you don't mind my asking," Douglas said, "but I noticed the statue outside, and are you guys Christian? I thought you were Indian." "There are Christians in India," Sanjeev replied. "But we are not."
“我不介意问一下，”道格拉斯说，“但我注意到外面的雕像，你们是基督徒吗？我以为你们是印度人。”“印度也有基督徒，”桑杰夫回答。“但我们不是。”
The bell rang again and again and again. Within minutes, it seemed, the house had filled with bodies and conversations and unfamiliar fragrances. The women wore heels and sheer stockings and short, black dresses made of crepe and chiffon. They handed their wraps and coats to Sanjeev, who draped them carefully on hangers in the spacious coat closet, though Twinkle told people to throw their things on the ottomans in the solarium.
门铃不停地响着。几分钟之内，房子里似乎就挤满了人和谈话声，还有陌生的香水味。女人们穿着高跟鞋、透明丝袜，穿着绉纱和雪纺制的黑色短裙。她们把披肩和外套递给桑杰夫，桑杰夫仔细地把它们挂在宽敞衣帽间的衣架上，尽管特温克尔告诉人们把东西扔在日光浴室的奥斯曼脚凳上。
It bewildered Sanjeev that it was for him and his house and his wife that they had all gone to so much care. Everyone congratulated him. Lester, another coworker, predicted that Sanjeev would be promoted to vice president in two months maximum.
这让桑杰夫感到困惑，他们竟然为了他、他的房子和他的妻子费了这么大的心。每个人都祝贺他。莱斯特，另一个同事，预测桑杰夫最多两个月就会升职为副总裁。
People devoured the samosas and dutifully admired the freshly painted ceilings and walls, the hanging plants, the bay windows, the silk paintings from Jaipur. But most of all, they admired Twinkle. Over hectic jazz records, played under Twinkle's supervision, they laughed at her anecdotes and observations, forming a widening circle around her, while Sanjeev replenished the samosas that he kept warming evenly in the oven, and getting ice for people's drinks, and opening more bottles of champagne with some difficulty, and explaining for the 40th time that he wasn't Christian.
人们狼吞虎咽地吃着萨莫萨三角饺，并礼貌地赞美着刚刷好的天花板和墙壁、悬挂的植物、凸窗、斋浦尔的丝绸画。但最重要的是，他们赞美特温克尔。在特温克尔监督下播放的快节奏爵士唱片中，他们对她的轶事和观察哈哈大笑，在她周围形成了一个越来越大的圈子，而桑杰夫则忙着补充他在烤箱里保持恒温的萨莫萨三角饺，为人们的饮料取冰，费劲地打开更多瓶香槟，并第40次解释他不是基督徒。
It was Twinkle who led them in separate groups up and down the winding stairs to gaze at the back lawn, to peer down the cellar steps. "Your friends adore the poster in my study," she mentioned to Sanjeev triumphantly, placing her hand on the small of his back as they, at one point, brushed past each other. Sanjeev went to the kitchen, which was empty, and ate a piece of chicken out of the tray on the counter with his fingers because he thought no one was looking. He ate a second piece, then washed it down with a gulp of gin, straight from the bottle.
是特温克尔领着他们分成不同的小组上上下下走动，去凝视后院草坪，去看地窖台阶。她在某一个点擦肩而过时，把手放在桑杰夫的后腰，得意地说：“你的朋友们太喜欢我书房里的海报了。”桑杰夫去了空荡荡的厨房，用手指从柜台上的托盘里拿了一块鸡肉吃，因为他觉得没人看见。他又吃了一块，然后直接对着瓶子喝了一大口金酒冲下。
Sunil, an anesthesiologist, walked in, spooning food from his paper plate into his mouth. "Great house. Great rice. Do you have any more champagne?"
苏尼尔，一位麻醉师，走了进来，用纸盘往嘴里勺着食物。“房子真棒。米饭真棒。还有香槟吗？”
"Your wife's wow," added Prabal, following behind. He was an unmarried professor of physics at Yale. For a moment, Sanjeev stared at him blankly, then blushed. Once, at a dinner party, Prabal had announced that Sophia Loren was wow, as was Audrey Hepburn.
“你妻子太棒了，”跟在后面的普拉巴尔补充道。他是一位在耶鲁大学任职的单身物理学教授。桑杰夫呆呆地看着他一会儿，然后脸红了。有一次在晚宴上，普拉巴尔曾宣布索菲亚·罗兰太棒了，奥黛丽·赫本也是。
Sunil picked a raisin out of the rice tray. "Twinkle, is her last name Little Star?" The two men laughed and started eating more rice from the tray, plowing through it with their plastic spoons. Sanjeev went down to the cellar for more liquor. For a few minutes, he paused on the steps in the damp, cool silence, hugging the second crate of champagne to his chest as the party drifted above the rafters. Then he set the reinforcements on the dining table.
苏尼尔从米饭托盘里挑出一颗葡萄干。“特温克尔，她的姓是‘小星星’吗？”两个男人大笑起来，继续从托盘里吃米饭，用塑料勺子大口地刨着。桑杰夫下到地窖拿更多的酒。有几分钟，他停在台阶上，在潮湿、阴凉的寂静中，把第二箱香槟抱在胸前，派对的声音在他头顶的椽子上漂浮。然后他把补充品放在餐桌上。
"Yes, everything. We found them all in the house in the most unusual places," he heard Twinkle saying in the living room. "In fact, we keep finding them." "No." "Yes. Every day is like a treasure hunt. It's too good. God only knows what else we'll find, no pun intended."
“是的，所有东西。我们是在房子的各个不寻常的地方发现它们的，”他听到特温克尔在客厅里说。“事实上，我们还在不断发现它们。”“不会吧。”“是的。每一天都像寻宝游戏。太棒了。上帝才知道我们还会发现什么，我没有用双关语的意思。”
That was what started it. As if by some unspoken pact, the whole party joined forces and began combing through each one of the rooms, opening closets on their own, peering under chairs and cushions, feeling behind curtains. Groups scampered, giggling and swaying, up and down the winding staircase. "We've never explored the attic," Twinkle announced suddenly, and so everybody followed. "How do we get up there?" "There's a ladder in the hallway, somewhere in the ceiling."
就是这样引发了一切。仿佛达成了某种默契，整个派对的人齐心协力，开始在每个房间里翻找，自发地打开壁橱，窥探椅子和垫子下面，在窗帘后面摸索。几组人嬉笑着，摇晃着，在回旋楼梯上下穿梭。“我们从来没去过阁楼，”特温克尔突然宣布，于是大家都跟了上去。“我们怎么上去？”“天花板里的走廊某处有个梯子。”
Wearily, Sanjeev followed at the back of the crowd to point out the location of the ladder. But Twinkle had already found it on her own. "Eureka!" she hollered.
桑杰夫疲惫地跟在人群最后，指出梯子的位置。但特温克尔已经自己找到了。“尤里卡！”她大喊道。
Douglas pulled the chain that released the steps. His face was flushed, and he was wearing Nora's feather hat on his head. One by one, the guests disappeared, men helping women as they placed their strappy high heels on the narrow slats of the ladder, the Indian women wrapping the free ends of their expensive saris into their waistbands. The men followed behind, all quickly disappearing, until Sanjeev alone remained at the top of the winding staircase.
道格拉斯拉动了释放梯子的链子。他的脸涨得通红，头上戴着诺拉的羽毛帽。客人们一个接一个消失了，男人们在女人们把带系带的高跟鞋放在梯子的窄条上时搀扶着她们，印度妇女们把昂贵纱丽的自由末端塞进腰带里。男人们紧随其后，都迅速消失，直到只剩下桑杰夫站在回旋楼梯的顶部。
Footsteps thundered over his head. He had no desire to join them. He wondered if the ceiling would collapse, imagined for a split second the sight of all the tumbling, drunk, perfumed bodies crashing, tangled, around him.
脚步声在他头顶轰鸣。他一点也不想加入他们。他怀疑天花板会不会塌，在脑海里想象了一秒钟所有这些翻滚着、醉醺醺的、充满香水味的身躯，纠缠在一起崩溃在他周围的样子。
He heard a shriek, and then rising, spreading waves of laughter in discordant tones. Something fell. Something else shattered. He could hear them babbling about a trunk. They seemed to be struggling to get it open, banging feverishly on its surface. He thought perhaps Twinkle would call for his assistance. But he was not summoned.
他听到一声尖叫，然后是阵阵升起、扩散开来的笑声，音调很不和谐。有什么东西掉了。什么东西碎了。他能听到他们喋喋不休地谈论着一个箱子。他们似乎在费力地想把它打开，狂热地撞击着它的表面。他心想也许特温克尔会叫他帮忙。但他没有被召唤。
He looked about the hallway and to the landing below, at the champagne glasses and half-eaten samosas and napkins smeared with lipstick, abandoned in every corner, on every available surface. Then he noticed that Twinkle, in her haste, had discarded her shoes altogether, for they lay by the foot of the ladder, black patent leather mules with heels like golf tees, opened toes, and slightly soiled silk labels on the instep, where her soles had rested. He placed them in the doorway of the master bedroom, so that no one would trip when they descended.
他环顾走廊和下面的着陆处，到处都是香槟杯、咬了一半的萨莫萨三角饺和涂满口红的餐巾纸，被丢弃在每个角落，每个可用的平面上。然后他注意到特温克尔匆忙之中把鞋子完全丢弃了，它们躺在梯子脚边，黑色漆皮骡子鞋，像高尔夫球钉一样的鞋跟，露趾，脚背上那丝质标签有点脏了，那是她脚掌歇过的地方。他把它们放在主卧室的门口，这样人们下来时就不会绊倒。
The strident voices had subsided to an even murmur. It occurred to Sanjeev that he had the house all to himself. The music had ended, and he could hear, if he concentrated, the hum of the refrigerator and the rustle of the last leaves on the trees outside. With one flick of his hand, he could snap the ladder back on its spring into the ceiling, and they would have no way of getting down, unless he were to pull the chain and let them.
刺耳的声音已经平息为均匀的低语。桑杰夫想到他现在整个房子里只有他一个人。音乐结束了，他如果集中注意力，能听到冰箱的嗡嗡声和外面树上最后几片落叶的沙沙声。只要手一弹，他就能把梯子弹回天花板里，除非他拉动链子让他们下来，否则他们就没法下来。
He thought of all the things he could do, undisturbed. He could sweep Twinkle's menagerie into a garbage bag and get in the car and drive it all to the dump, and tear down the poster of weeping Jesus, and take a hammer to the Virgin Mary while he was at it. Then he would return to the empty house. He could easily clear up the cups and plates in an hour's time, and pour himself a gin and tonic, and eat a plate of warmed rice, and listen to his new Bach CD, while reading the liner notes so as to understand it properly.
他想到了所有他可以做的、不受干扰的事情。他可以把特温克尔的“珍品”扫进垃圾袋，开车去垃圾场，撕掉哭泣耶稣的海报，顺便用锤子砸烂圣母玛利亚像。然后他回到空荡荡的房子。他可以轻松地在一小时内清理掉杯子和盘子，给自己倒一杯金汤力，吃一盘加热过的米饭，听他的新巴赫CD，同时阅读封套说明以便正确理解。
He nudged the ladder slightly, but it was sturdily planted against the door. Budging it would require some effort. "My God, I need a cigarette," Twinkle exclaimed from above.
他轻轻推了推梯子，但它稳稳地顶在门上。挪动它需要一点力气。“天哪，我需要抽根烟，”特温克尔在上面惊呼。
Sanjeev felt knots forming at the back of his neck. He felt dizzy. He needed to lie down. He walked towards the bedroom, but stopped short when he saw Twinkle's shoes facing him in the doorway.
桑杰夫感觉到脖子后面形成了结。他感到头晕。他需要躺下。他走向卧室，但在看到特温克尔的鞋子对着他摆在门口时停住了。
He thought of her slipping them on her feet. But instead of feeling irritated, as he had ever since they'd moved into the house together, he felt a pang of anticipation at the thought of her rushing unsteadily down the winding staircase in them, scratching the floor a bit in her path. The pang intensified as he thought of her rushing to the bathroom to brighten her lipstick, and eventually rushing to get people their coats, and finally rushing to the cherrywood table when the last guest had left to begin opening their housewarming presents.
他想到她穿上它们的样子。但与其感到恼火，像他们搬进这房子以来那样，他感到一种期待的刺痛，一想到她穿着它们摇摇晃晃地沿着回旋楼梯冲下来，在路上把地板刮出一点痕迹，那刺痛就加剧了。当他想到她冲进洗手间补口红，最终冲去帮人们拿外套，并最终在最后一位客人离开时冲到樱桃木桌子旁开始打开暖房礼物时，那种刺痛更加强烈了。
It was the same pang that he used to feel before they were married, when he would hang up the phone after one of their conversations, or when he would drive back from the airport, wondering which ascending plane in the sky was hers. "Sanj, you won't believe this." She emerged with her back to him, her hands over her head, the tops of her bare shoulder blades perspiring, supporting something still hidden from view. "You got it, Twinkle?" someone asked. "Yes, you can let go."
那种刺痛和他婚前感到的一样，当时他在结束通话后挂断电话，或者当他从机场开车回来，猜测天空中哪架飞机是她的时候。“桑杰，你绝对不会相信这个。”她背对他冒出来，双手放在头顶，赤裸的肩胛骨顶部渗出汗水，支撑着某种依然看不见的东西。“你拿到了，特温克尔？”有人问。“是的，你们可以放手了。”
Now he saw that her hands were wrapped around it, a solid silver bust of Christ, the head easily three times the size of his own. It had a patrician bump on its nose, magnificent, curly hair that rested atop a pronounced collarbone, and a broad forehead that reflected in miniature the walls and doors and lampshades around them. Its expression was confident, as if assured of its devotees, the unyielding lips sensuous and full. It was also sporting Nora's feather hat.
现在他看到她的手环绕着它，一个实心的银色基督半身像，头颅的大小轻易就是他自己的三倍。它有一个贵族式的鼻梁，浓密的卷发停在一个凸出的锁骨上，宽阔的前额微缩地映射出周围的墙壁、门和灯罩。它的表情充满自信，仿佛确信自己的虔诚者，不屈的嘴唇丰满而感性。它还戴着诺拉的羽毛帽。
As Twinkle descended, Sanjeev put his hands around her waist to balance her. And he relieved her of the bust when she had reached the ground. It weighed a good 30 pounds. The others began lowering themselves slowly, exhausted from the hunt. Some trickled downstairs in search of a fresh drink.
当特温克尔下来时，桑杰夫双手搂住她的腰帮她平衡。当她落地时，他帮她接过了半身像。它足有30磅重。其他人开始慢慢降下来，狩猎让他们精疲力竭。有些人流向楼下寻找新鲜饮料。
She took a breath, raised her eyebrows, crossed her fingers. "Would you mind terribly if we displayed it on the mantle, just for tonight? I know you hate it." He did hate it. He hated its immensity, and its flawless, polished surface, and its undeniable value. He hated that it was in his house and that he owned it.
她深吸一口气，扬起眉毛，交叉着手指。“如果你不介意的话，我们把它放在壁炉台面上展示，只展示今晚，好吗？我知道你讨厌它。”他确实讨厌它。他讨厌它的巨大，讨厌它毫无瑕疵、闪闪发光的表面，讨厌它不可否认的价值。他讨厌它在他的房子里，讨厌他拥有它。
Unlike the other things they'd found, this contained dignity, solemnity, beauty even. But to his surprise, these qualities made him hate it all the more. Most of all, he hated it because he knew that Twinkle loved it.
与他们发现的其他东西不同，这个东西包含着尊严、庄重，甚至美丽。但令他惊讶的是，这些品质让他更加讨厌它。最重要的是，他讨厌它，因为他知道特温克尔爱它。
"I'll keep it in my study from tomorrow," Twinkle added. "I promise." She would never put it in her study, he knew. For the rest of their days together, she would keep it on the center of the mantle, flanked on either side by the rest of the menagerie. Each time they had guests, Twinkle would explain how she had found it, and they would admire her as they listened. He gazed at the crushed rose petals in her hair, at the pearl and sapphire choker at her throat, at the sparkly crimson polish on her toes. He decided that these were among the things that made Prabal think she was wow.
“从明天开始，我就把它放在我的书房里，”特温克尔补充道。“我保证。”他知道她永远不会把它放进书房。在他们共度的余生里，她会把它放在壁炉台的中心，两边陈列着其余的那些珍品。每次有客人来，特温克尔都会解释她是怎样发现它的，而他们会在聆听时赞美她。他凝视着她发丝里压碎的玫瑰花瓣，她喉咙上的珍珠蓝宝石颈圈，她脚趾上闪闪发光的深红色指甲油。他认定这些就是让普拉巴尔认为她太棒了的原因。
His head ached from gin, and his arms ached from the weight of the statue. He said, "I put your shoes in the bedroom." Twinkle gave his elbow a little squeeze and headed for the living room. "Thanks, but my feet are killing me." Sanjeev pressed the massive silver face to his ribs, careful not to let the feather hat slip, and followed her.
他的头因为金酒而作痛，胳膊因为雕像的重量而酸痛。他说：“我把你的鞋放卧室了。”特温克尔捏了捏他的手肘，向客厅走去。“谢谢，但我的脚疼得要命。”桑杰夫把厚重的银色脸庞紧贴在自己的肋骨上，小心不让羽毛帽滑落，跟着她走了过去。
Mira Nair, reading a slightly abridged version of Jhumpa Lahiri's story, "This Blessed House," from the book The Interpreter of Maladies, which is such a great book, also winner of the Pulitzer Prize. Mira Nair, who read, is the director of Monsoon Wedding, Mississippi Masala, Vanity Fair, and other films.
米拉·奈尔，阅读了Jhumpa Lahiri的《这个受祝福的家》的一个略微删减的版本，选自那本伟大的书《疾病解说者》，也是普利策奖得主。阅读者米拉·奈尔是《季风婚宴》、《密西西比马萨拉》、《名利场》和其他电影的导演。
[MUSIC - "HALLELUJAH" BY JOHN CALE]
[音乐 - 约翰·凯尔的“哈利路亚”]
Act Three, The Lie That Binds. You could argue that it is impossible to stay in any relationship for very long without sometimes traveling under fake papers, without sometimes concealing what you think. I say this, and I don't mean it cynically. I mean being in love sometimes means not saying what is going through your head. David Sedaris lives in Paris with his boyfriend, Hugh, and he provides this case example.
第三幕，“束缚的谎言”。你可以争论说，如果不偶尔使用假证件，如果不偶尔隐藏你的真实想法，想要在任何关系中长时间维持下去是不可能的。我这样说，并不是愤世嫉俗。我的意思是，身处爱中，有时意味着不说出你脑子里真正想的东西。大卫·塞达里斯和他的男友休住在巴黎，他提供了这个案例。
Last night, Hugh and I went around the corner to see The End of the Affair, a Neil Jordan adaptation of the Graham Greene novel. He sobbed from beginning to end. And by the time we left the theater, the poor thing was completely dehydrated.
昨晚，休和我去了街角看《爱到尽头》，尼尔·乔丹改编的格雷厄姆·格林的同名小说。他从头哭到尾。当我们离开电影院时，那个可怜的东西完全脱水了。
I asked if he always cried during comedies, and he accused me of being grossly insensitive, a charge I'm trying to plea bargain down to a simple obnoxious. Looking back, I should've known better than to accompany Hugh to a love story. Such movies are always a danger as, unlike battling aliens or going undercover to track a serial killer, falling in love is something most adults have actually experienced at some point in their lives.
我问他是不是看喜剧时也总是哭，他指责我极其麻木不仁，这个指控我正试图辩解为仅仅是讨厌。回想起来，我早该知道不该陪休去看爱情片。这类电影总是很危险，因为与对抗外星人或卧底追踪连环杀手不同，坠入爱河是大多数成年人实际上在生命中的某个阶段都经历过的事情。
The theme is universal and encourages the viewer to make a number of unhealthy comparisons, leading to the question, "Why can't our lives be like that?" It's a box best left unopened. And its avoidance explains the continued popularity of vampire epics and martial arts extravaganzas.
这个主题是普遍的，鼓励观众进行许多不健康的比较，从而引发问题：“为什么我们的生活不能像那样？”这是一个最好不要打开的盒子。而避免触碰它，解释了吸血鬼史诗和武术奇观依然流行的原因。
The End of the Affair made me look like an absolute toad. The movie's voracious couple was played by Ralph Fiennes and Julianne Moore, who did everything but eat one another. Their love was doomed and clandestine, and even when the bombs were falling, they looked radiant. Something about Julianne Moore and Ralph Fiennes put me on the defensive.
《爱到尽头》让我看起来像个十足的癞蛤蟆。电影中那对贪婪的情侣由拉尔夫·费因斯和朱丽安·摩尔扮演，他们几乎无所不为，甚至要吃掉对方。他们的爱注定失败且秘而不宣，即使炸弹落下，他们看起来依然光彩照人。朱丽安·摩尔和拉尔夫·费因斯之间某种东西让我陷入了防御状态。
I'm not as unfeeling as Hugh accuses me of being, but things change once you've been together for 10 years. They rarely make movies about long-term couples and for good reason. Our lives are boring.
我不像休指责的那样麻木，但一旦你们在一起十年，事情就会改变。他们很少拍摄关于长期伴侣的电影，这有很好的理由。我们的生活很无聊。
The courtship had its moments, but now we've become the predictable part two no one in his right mind would ever pay to see. Hugh and I have been together for so long that in order to arouse extraordinary passion, we need to engage in actual physical combat. Once, he hit me on the back of the head with a broken wine glass, and I fell to the floor, pretending to be unconscious. That was romantic, or would have been had he rushed to my side, rather than stepping over my body to fetch the dustpan.
求爱期或许有一些高光时刻，但现在我们已经成了没人会想花钱去看的、可预测的续集。休和我在一起太久了，以至于为了激发出非凡的激情，我们需要进行实际的肢体战斗。有一次，他用破酒杯砸我的后脑勺，我倒在地上，假装昏迷。那是浪漫的，或者说，如果他当时赶过来照顾我，而不是跨过我的身体去拿簸箕的话，那本来会是浪漫的。
Call me unimaginative, but I still can't think of anyone else I'd rather be with. On our worst days, I figure things will work themselves out. Otherwise, I really don't give it much thought.
你可以说我缺乏想象力，但我依然想不出还有谁比他更适合我。在最糟糕的日子里，我心想事情总会解决的。否则，我真的不会对此多加思考。
Neither of us would ever publicly display affection. We're just not that type. We can't profess love without talking through hand puppets, and we'd never consciously sit down to discuss our relationship. These, to me, are good things. They were fine with Hugh as well until he saw that damn movie and was reminded that he has other options.
我们两人都不会在公开场合展示亲密。我们不是那种类型。我们无法在不使用手偶的情况下表达爱意，我们也永远不会坐下来有意识地讨论我们的关系。对我来说，这些是好事。这对休来说也很好，直到他看了那部该死的电影，并被提醒他还有其他选择。
The picture ended at around 10:00. And afterwards, we went for coffees at a little place across the street from the Luxembourg Gardens. I was ready to wipe the movie out of my mind, but Hugh was still under its spell. He looked as though his life had not only passed him by, but paused along the way to spit in his face.
电影在10点左右结束。之后，我们去卢森堡公园对面的一家小店喝咖啡。我准备把这部电影从脑子里擦掉，但休依然深受其影响。他看起来就好像他的人生不仅从他身边溜走，还在路上停下来吐在他脸上。
Our coffees arrived, and as he blew his nose into a napkin, I encouraged him to look on the bright side. "Listen," I said, "We maybe don't live in wartime London, but in terms of the occasional bomb scare, Paris is a pretty close second. We both love taxidermy. We take vacations to fun places like Croatia. What more could you possibly want?"
我们的咖啡到了，当他对着餐巾纸擤鼻涕时，我鼓励他看光明的一面。“听着，”我说，“我们或许不住在战时的伦敦，但就偶尔的炸弹恐慌而言，巴黎是相当接近的第二名。我们都喜欢标本制作。我们去克罗地亚这样有趣的地方度假。你还想怎么样？”
What more could he want? It was an incredibly stupid question. And when he failed to answer, I was reminded of just how lucky I truly am.
他还能想要什么？这是一个极其愚蠢的问题。当他没能回答时，我意识到自己是多么幸运。
Movie characters might chase one another through the fog, or race down the stairs of burning buildings, but that's just for beginners. Real love amounts to withholding the truth, even when you're offered the perfect opportunity to hurt somebody's feelings. I wanted to say something to this effect, but my hand puppets were back home in their drawer. Instead, I pulled my chair a few inches closer, and we sat silently at our little table on the square, looking for all the world like two people in love.
电影角色可能会在雾中追逐对方，或从着火建筑的楼梯上赛跑，但这只是入门。真实的爱情等同于隐瞒真相，即使是在你可以完美伤到某人情感的时候。我本想说些类似的话，但我的手偶还在家里的抽屉里。相反，我把椅子拉近了几英寸，我们默默地坐在广场上的小桌前，看起来就像世界上两个相爱的人。
David Sedaris is the author most recently of Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim . He also edited the collection Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules , an anthology of outstanding stories.
大卫·塞达里斯是《给你的家人穿上灯芯绒和丹宁》的作者。他还编辑了文集《在赫拉克勒斯雕像前玩耍的孩子》，这是一部优秀故事集。
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Seth Lind, Sam Hallgren, Chris Neary, and Thea Chaloner.
我们的节目今天由温迪·多尔和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·基恩。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。Todd Bachmann、Seth Lind、Sam Hallgren、Chris Neary和Thea Chaloner协助制作。
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download audio of our program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，您可以免费收听我们的节目，或购买CD。您也可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目和存档的音频。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who never suspected, never, not for a second.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由Torey Malatia先生负责，他从未怀疑过，从未，哪怕是一秒钟。
Oh my God, wow. Really? You're a Jew? Wow, that's so exciting.
噢，我的天，哇。真的吗？你是犹太人？哇，那太令人激动了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。